the nexus what is a person
people are different i do not mean
one from another although they are that
but they are different in kind
to everything else in the universe
starkly different it's not like
cockroaches are a little different from
ants
bees a little different again
hummingbirds different still
than parrots flying foxes still fly but
they're a little bit different
perhaps more so cats different again
koalas look
more cuddly as we move along the
continuum than monkeys
and so the smooth transition of
differences goes on to
chimpanzees and bonobos and we're just
next
right no
everything was more or less fine until
the claim that
we're next as if we're on the same
continuum
we are not in the same way that the leaf
still growing on the branch is different
in kind
to the rocks below or indeed the plant
different to the bee
in kind so are we different to all
other species yes rocks and leaves have
some similarities
both are made of atoms but so much for
that
it is the differences that really matter
life and non-life are different in kind
there are many ways
school students learn of the differences
but the real difference between
the living and the never was alive come
down to the presence or absence of
genetic information
life grows life reproduces life passes
on information from one generation to
the next and that information it passes
on
is in response to encounters with the
environment
plants and animals are different in kind
too do we need to spell out the ways
i guess some might need to be reminded
plants utilize
photosynthesis they are autotrophs they
can make their own food
animals cannot do this they must
physically move from place to place in
order to eat
animals tend to have somewhat more
complex nervous systems while plants
lack almost any sign of having sense
organs
that's not to say they have none but
compared to an animal it's not much
they cannot encode information about the
environment around them
and represent it in some way in a
nervous system
which is to say in a computer of a kind
whatever the case i labor this point
because it is clear to people
i guess because they are taught this
among other things that there is a clear
line to be drawn between the living and
the non-living
and then within the living between the
plants and the animals both the
non-living
and the living have many similarities
and we could list them
so too with plants and animals but does
anyone doubt that it is the differences
that are the really interesting thing
here but humans are unique for another
reason
they often want to deny how unique they
are as a species we stand apart from all
other life on earth
on the one hand many will immediately
recognize to the point of celebration
all the damage we can do to the planet
so we are taught
so on the one hand we are different in
kind we are uniquely destructive
it is said but even if we were to grant
this
where does that capacity for being
uniquely destructive come from
it comes from our capacity to control
the environment around us
it comes from our capacity to be
uniquely creative
but where does that come from it comes
from our capacity to explain it
to explain something means to give an
account of what
really exists out there in the world and
how those things that exist
have relationships between them which
allow for the evolution over time
of physical systems a person can
not only explain the world in which it
finds itself our world is such that it
is always
explicable by people this follows from a
momentous discovery in science
about the relationship between physics
and computation
computation is that field of study
concerned with how to calculate the
answer to mathematical problems
it was once thought that such a field of
study was itself part of
pure mathematics being a part of pure
mathematics it was further thought that
it could be discussed without ever
worrying about what the laws of physics
actually were
but how does a computer do what it does
according to some histories of this
and there are competing stories alan
turing was the first to formalize a
system of computation
it's a simple idea take an infinitely
long strip of paper
we're doing pure mathematics here after
all so we can have infinitely long
strips of paper
and divide it into squares each square
is either blank or it has a symbol on it
now a computer on this view is now a
device that can read whether or not
there is a symbol on the square
or not and further it can write a new
symbol or eraser symbol before moving on
to the next square
whether the machine moves onto the next
square let's say to the right along the
strip
or to the left or stops all depends on
the program that the programmer has
written for it
a set of instructions now the remarkable
thing about such a device
is that it can be instructed to compute
anything that is computable
no matter what the mathematical problem
if it is computable and not all
mathematical questions
are computable not by a long shot if it
is computable
then the turing machine can compute it
indeed
turing's whole purpose was to solve a
problem in pure mathematics
mathematics given what most people
thought then and the popular conception
now
is just a mechanical process of
following rules the rules of inference
or the rules of mathematics
so then it should be possible for a
machine to just do the math by following
the rules for whatsoever mathematical
problem could be posed to it
for reasons beyond the scope of what i'm
talking about here and now
that claim was shown to be false
mathematics is not
purely mechanical there are just some
mathematical questions
the machine cannot find an answer to for
one reason
for some questions it will just run and
run forever without ever being able to
find the answer
this is just one among many other issues
involving the creativity
of mathematicians as being central to
discovery of mathematical knowledge
now one amazing thing about the laws of
physics as we know them
are that they are expressible
mathematically as computable
functions turing computable functions in
other words
the laws of physics are during
computable by a turing machine
and this is actually the answer to that
long-standing question posed by eugene
wigner
about the so-called unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics in the
natural sciences
the fact is that the laws of physics the
laws of nature
are not only mathematically informed but
turing-computable
so this is why mathematics is effective
in the physical sciences
the physical sciences governed by
physical laws which assuring computable
and a mathematical process or proof
is a kind of computation but a problem
looms here the laws of quantum theory
reveal that matter even something as
simple as the motion of electrons moving
in place around a nucleus
is not so simple the problem of how to
compute the position of the electrons at
any time in the future given their
present state
while computable cannot be efficiently
computed by a turing machine
which is to say for problems like this
even if the turing machine was operating
at the speed of light
it might still take the lifetime of the
universe to calculate where the
electrons would be
some minutes from now as richard feynman
quipped about the early pioneers of
computation
they thought they understood paper by
which he meant the turing machine itself
is actually a real machine it is not
merely imaginary or the product of pure
mathematical intuition or something like
that
whatever that might be it must be made
out of physical stuff
like paper and that obeys the laws of
quantum theory
so it was david deutch who in 1985
published a paper
titled quantum theory the church turing
thesis and the universal quantum
computer
while turing had assumed that his
machine operated according to classical
laws of physics
in a kind of abstract space deutsche
brought this down to earth
he applied the actual laws of quantum
theory that govern the universe
to turing's machine and a new mode of
computation was born
the turing machine was still universal
that did not change
but now it was made out of actual paper
or actual matter
and not an idealized kind of abstract
paper obeying fictional laws
but rather stuff obeying the actual laws
of physics
quantum physics strangely enough
the real world is even more powerful
than turing imagined because actual
matter
actual paper so to speak a proper
understanding of the matter paper is
made of
allowed for the efficient computation of
things like
electrons orbiting nuclei in atoms what
might have taken the classical universal
turing machine
the lifetime of the universe might now
take only minutes with a quantum
computer
for some tasks like for example
simulating or modeling quantum systems
like atoms or electrons interacting
thus was the birth of quantum
computation an entire
industry and a race to building the
first universal quantum computer
which we still do not have but we will
one day because it is physically
possible so if we just keep on
correcting errors and improving our
knowledge and technology
whatever is not prohibited by the laws
of physics is possible
given the right knowledge but what this
also means
is that anything that exists in physical
reality can be simulated by a quantum
computer
atoms can be stars solar systems and
galaxies can be whole universes can be
and anything in them anything including
people including their brains the brain
of a person is a physical system
whatever it is doing it is doing
according to the laws of physics
and because of this it can in principle
be simulated by a quantum computer
now this might very well mean a quantum
computer of the distant future could
simulate
every atom in a human brain and
therefore replicate the processes
in a human brain inside of a quantum
computer what this might be like for
such a simulated brain is anyone's guess
but we should not deny that such a
simulation would be a person
a person is the software running on the
brain so a simulation
of a piece of software is that piece of
software so a simulation of a person
is a person so therefore a moral hazard
is before us here that we should be
eager to solve
long before we try to do such a thing
would switching
off the simulation be like putting the
person to death would switching it
on be a form of torture absent
human-like senses would the person in
the simulation be in a terrible
nightmarish void of nothingness
or at a confusion like a terrible but
unending acid trip
somehow coupled with the knowledge that
one is being simulated
would that person in the simulation have
all the memories of the physical brain
that it has just simulated presumably so
and presumably that is reason enough
never to try the experiment
in precisely this way but it may be
and we expect it to be the case that
simulating every single atom in a brain
would not be needed to simulate a person
instead we just need to simulate that
part of the brain that is doing the
actual computations
in particular the necessary parts of the
brain that are able to conjecture
explanations of everything else
that is what a person is after all a
universal explainer
if we can simulate just that part that
is enough
in order to simulate a person in order
to create a person
but we have very little idea of course
precisely
where in the brain and how these
computations are performed nor more
importantly
what the program is that instructs the
brain
to compute from one moment to the next
which is to say
we do not know what the mind is in terms
of what the code might be or what the
algorithm might be
written to capture the process that is
the mind
the process that generates knowledge
creates explanations
seeks to comprehend the world around it
these are all synonymous
and we do not know what the code for any
of them are
a person uniquely unlike everything else
in the known universe
can create explanations those
explanations are a sign of the person
gradually coming to comprehend the world
in which it finds itself
what does it mean to comprehend
something understanding
to comprehend or understand something is
to complete a certain kind of
computation
that is after all what the brain is
doing it is computing things
that part of the brain that deals with
computing models of the world or
explanations
is the software more commonly referred
to as the mind
not all of the brain is a mind
conjecturing explanations much is
dealing with largely unconscious
processes monitoring sleep cycles
whether one is hungry and so on
but the mind does seek to understand
which means it
seeks to create inside of itself some
kind of model of what is
outside as well as inside this is the
sense in which we say that
if the laws of physics are
comprehensible they must be capable of
being embodied in another physical
object
the noah if the laws of physics were
such they could not be embodied
elsewhere
like the mind of a person then this
would mean the attempt to comprehend the
laws of physics would be impossible
but this is not the world we are in we
are in a world where computation can be
universal
there can be devices that can compute
anything that is computable
and the laws of physics are computable
they consist of computable mathematical
functions
that simply is provably the case there
is nothing in the standard model or
quantum field theory or general
relativity the laws of thermodynamics
construct a theory or string theory if
you want to go that way that contain
within
them non-computable functions the
functions used by physics are computable
the laws of physics are computable as
such a computer can be programmed to
simulate what the laws of physics are
doing
one such computer is the human brain the
human brain being able to explain
things in the first place to create
knowledge is thus able in principle to
comprehend
to understand those laws of physics we
might also wonder along with the british
historian lord mccauley
who wrote in response to the pessimists
of his time
on what principle is it that with
nothing but improvement behind us
we're to expect nothing but
deterioration before us
we could paraphrase that wonderful quip
too how is it that with nothing but
simplifications and unifications behind
us
we are to expect a wall of complexity
and incomprehensibility before us
in other words our grand and deepest
theories explain more become more
unified and are not impenetrably complex
despite what we are taught at school and
university
and the way in which we are taught those
things
understanding is just a physical process
it is in truth identical to the act of
creating the knowledge in the first
place
that aha moment people get when they
understand something it's precisely the
same feeling
as the scientist who gets it for the
first time ever it is just different in
degree perhaps not in kind
the first person ever einstein to
understand that accelerations and
gravity are two sides of the same coin
that for example an elevator which is
stationary on the ground will cause the
occupants to experience precisely the
same sensations
as the same elevator in deep space
accelerating at 9.8 meters per second
per second
this is known as the equivalent
principle between gravitation and
acceleration
he called this his happiest thought now
if you understand that same principle
you may have a happy thought too
a happy sensation of comprehension of
course it's tempered by the fact that
well firstly you're not the first ever
to have understood that
and secondly einstein may of course have
understood things a little more deeply
because he'd been pondering that same
problem
for hours a day for years at a time
and so his happy thought was probably
deeper but not different in kind
whatever the case understanding is
creating knowledge and creating
knowledge is a process that minds do
it is about modeling being embodied in a
mind
this is where we talk about
self-similarity the idea that a mind can
contain within it
a working model of the rest of physical
reality to some arbitrary degree of
accuracy
we are always scratching the surface so
the model is never perfect but in
principle
anything that exists can be represented
or embodied
in the mind of a person including the
person this is the self-similarity part
a part of a person is just like in some
respects
the rest of everything else and it
becomes more and more like
the rest over time as it learns more so
i should just
pause here and have a little diversion
on this
concept of self-similarity and
self-similarity
is a concept out of mathematics it's
often used when discussing things like
fractals
fractals being these patterns that
emerge from rather simple mathematical
formulae
where no matter how much you magnify
a part of the fractal it looks the same
as
the part of the fractal that was not
magnified it continues to repeat itself
in a sense that the smaller parts
are similar to the larger parts of the
fractal
now in physical reality we have things
like this as well
coastlines for example the more that you
magnify the coastline
the more that it looks like the
coastline from a greater distance away
it's self-similar it's similar to itself
now the kind of
self-similarity that is invoked in the
work of david deutsch when it comes to
knowledge and the laws of physics is
deeper than this
it's about how structures in the mind
are similar to other parts of physical
reality
and this is a kind of unique aspect to
the minds of people
the example that's used by david deutsch
is a wonderful one
he's used it in his ted talks he uses it
in the beginning of infinity
where he compares our physical
understanding
of what's going on with a quasar a
quasar is
an extremely distant very luminous
object
which we think is a black hole
gradually consuming stars and as a
consequence of this process of a
black hole consuming a star a very
violent high energy process
vast quantities of energy and light are
produced and we can detect that from
here on earth
we can see using our telescopes these
extremely distant objects
quasars quasi-stellar radio sources more
luminous than entire galaxies
our most powerful telescopes can see
these quasars
what does that have to do with
self-similarity well let's consider our
knowledge of quasars
let's consider our understanding of what
a quasar really is
our understanding of what a quasar
really is is as i described
a black hole consuming stars and as a
consequence
the accretion disk which is the disk of
material that is falling into the black
hole
is rotating so quickly that it creates
magnetic fields the reason it creates
magnetic fields is because
this gas that is spiraling into the
black hole
is ionized ionized gas ionized gas
means you have an electrical current of
a kind
an ion is a charged particle so lots of
them moving together constitute an
electric current
and all the way back in the 1800s we had
people like
michael faraday explaining how moving
charges
like electrons or in this case ions can
generate magnetic fields
these magnetic fields that are generated
cause the production
of jets of material that head in all
directions but in
in our case towards the earth which we
can see which we can detect
and which allow us of course via our
telescopes via the detection of this
light
to thereby understand the process which
is producing
this phenomena that we see so out there
in reality
we have this thing called a quasar which
is an extremely
violent unusual object and as david says
the physics of the quasar
could not be more unlike the physics of
the brain
what's this got to do with
self-similarity well despite the fact
that the physics of the quasar is so
different
to the physics of the brain nonetheless
there's something in the brain
of the relevant astrophysicists with the
relevant knowledge
that is similar similar to the quasa
what's similar the mathematical
relationships
of the parts of the explanation
describing and explaining what's going
on in that quasar
is similar to what is actually going on
with the matter in the quasar the matter
in the quasar is obeying physical laws
and those physical laws have
mathematical relationships between them
the relationship between the physical
forces and the matter what is physically
going on on the other side of the
universe
in that quasar is replicated and similar
to what's going on between the abstract
ideas and the mathematical relationships
between those abstract ideas
in the mind of a physicist who
understands the quasar and as we come to
understand quasars more and more
the fidelity or the accuracy with which
that explanation comes to resemble
the actual quasar out there increases
over time
we gain a more accurate model as we
correct the errors
in our understanding of that thing over
there so this is
what self-similarity is that structures
separated not only by distance but
separated by
the kind of matter and relationships
that make them up in other words
the relationships that make up what's
going on in the neurons inside the brain
and the relationships between what's
going on with the
particles of accreted material from the
star being consumed by the quasar
come to have a similarity between them
not so much a superficial visual
similarity
but rather a deeper similarity there is
a one-to-one correspondence between
the ideas of the astrophysicist coming
to understand the quater
and the physical processes going on
inside the quasar
now there's a further way in which this
is self-similarity of the universe
namely not only does the astrophysicist
over time come to have a visual and
mathematical
representation a model of the quasar in
their mind that increases in its
accuracy over time as
the astrophysicist comes to learn more
about that quasar but this is true of
every physical process in the entire
universe everything that we begin to
learn about
we are creating models of so we are
creating models of
all the other stuff that's out there in
the universe inside of human minds
there are models of the rest of physical
reality
the human mind is coming to understand
with increasing fidelity
over time the rest of physical reality
so the mathematical relationships that
exist
out there between physical objects are
coming to be represented
by abstract objects inside the mind of
physicists
and a further level of self-similarity
is
the human being the person is coming to
understand all the stuff out there
and the stuff that's in here as well we
come to understand our own psychology
better over time as well
this is of course just in its very
nascent beginnings our understanding of
our own mental state but as that
increases as well
then we kind of have this feedback
between
the self-similarity in our minds of the
rest of physical reality as well as
ourselves which are also part of
physical reality it's kind of a
recursive
learning that's going on and so we are
becoming more and more similar
in terms of our knowledge to the rest of
objective reality out there
these two things are coming to resemble
each other in
deep fundamental ways
again we do not have a very good
explanation of exactly what a person is
but a person is made of matter obeying
physical laws
and so that matter can be in principle
simulated
because the laws of physics are
turing-computable and understanding is
just a kind of computation it is
something minds do
this means the laws of physics are such
that they mandate their own
comprehensibility
which is an astonishing fact logically
it did not need to be this way it is not
logically necessary that the laws of
physics be computable but they are that
is a contingent
empirical fact about our world the laws
of physics could have consisted of
functions
not computable or the laws might have
been such that computation was not
possible
or that universal computation was not
possible or quantum theory was false in
all sorts of ways
or it could have been that there were
two substances in the world mata obeying
physical laws
and spirits in the spiritual world and
the soul that doesn't that operated by
means other than physical processes
now some people do insist on this it
should be said whenever anyone
says understanding is not computing they
are appealing to the supernatural they
are saying that
something a mind does is not physical
not governed by the laws of physics
but the rest of us are scientific
realists we defer to the best
explanation we do not
jump to supernatural ideas because we do
not like the sound
of what conclusions follow from our best
scientific theories
we take our best scientific theories
seriously
and so that matter can be in principle
simulated
because the laws of physics are turing
computable and understanding is just a
kind of computation
it is something minds do this means the
laws of physics
are such that they mandate their own
comprehensibility
so let's unpack that claim
that the laws of physics mandate their
own
comprehensibility well we have to begin
with the notion that there is this law
of physics
there is this law of physics proven
mathematically by david deutsch in his
seminal 1985 paper
now that that paper let's just remind
ourselves
of that paper it's titled quantum theory
the church tutoring principle and the
universal quantum computer
okay so let's just consider what the
church turing principle or hypothesis
is what turing said the way turing wrote
it and i'm just quoting from david's
paper he said
every function which would naturally be
regarded as computable
can be computed by the universal turing
machine
okay so that's what turing said
with respect to his principle all
computable things can be computed
by a turing machine by a computer in
other words
it almost sounds like a tautology
it's a principle it wasn't proven until
david proved it with this paper and how
did he prove it
well he proved it by assuming
rightly that computers have to be made
of stuff
they have to be made of matter the
matter
obeys the laws of physics what are the
laws of physics
the quantum laws of physics now does
that mean the quantum laws of physics of
the final forever
word on what the laws of physics are no
so what he's doing is using
our best knowledge of what the laws of
physics are now it could be wrong
but what else can we do it could be that
general relativity is wrong
it could be we're all living in a
simulation all these silly claims about
we could be wrong of course we always
could be wrong
but we don't make much progress assuming
we're wrong
unless we have somewhere better to jump
to unless someone has a better idea
simply assuming
that our best knowledge is wrong doesn't
get us very far and left
unless we have something better to
replace it with so assuming
quantum theory is correct
then assuming that real physical
computers obey quantum theory
applying quantum theory to computation
we can make a few other claims
like for example the laws of physics
consist of turing computable functions
so this just simply is the case all the
ways in which
we express the laws in quantum theory
and elsewhere by the way but in quantum
theory in particular
is via computable functions it's not
like there's a
law of physics in quantum theory that is
not computable
it's computable which means given that
all matter
conforms obeys quantum theory
then that means any physical process
that happens anywhere in the universe at
any time
is going to be able to be computable by
a turing machine
why because a turing machine a universal
turing machine operating
via laws of quantum theory
is going to be able to simulate any
physical system
in the universe made of physical stuff
because that physical physical stuff is
obeying the laws of quantum theory
the very laws which themselves are
computable
now as david says in his paper he says
every finitely realizable
physical system can be perfectly
simulated by a universal model computing
machine operating by finite means
now this by the way has been amended and
i think he
was i'm not sure i think he was required
to put something like that in there by
an editor or something but in fact the
better way to phrase
that sentence is that every finitely
realizable physical system
can be arbitrarily accurately
simulated by a universal model computing
machine operating by finite means
in other words every finitely realizable
physical system so every
physical system that's out there okay
everything that really exists out there
in the known universe
can be simulated to whatever degree of
accuracy you like
by a universal computing machine okay
a quantum computer can do this because
inside of the quantum computer you could
have a simulation
of an atom for example now this could be
done by a classical
turing computer you could have an
atom simulated inside of a classical
laptop problem is that it's not going to
be
very accurate at all it's going to be
very very slow in order to calculate
things like
where the electrons are from moment to
moment why because where the electrons
around a nucleus are from moment to
moment is governed by the laws of
quantum theory
and it says that there are many many
many many places
that the electrons can be from moment to
moment as they orbit the nucleus this is
one of the great insights of
quantum theory so you're presented with
a problem that although
a normal computer a classical computer a
classical turing machine
operating according to the laws of
classical physics
would be able to simulate an atom if you
want to predict where the electrons are
going to be
a minute from now around that nucleus
what you're going to find is that your
classical computer is going to grind to
a halt
all the possibilities that come together
to enable you to predict
the position and the velocity of these
electrons as they're going around the
nucleus
from moment to moment it's going to
exponentially spiral into and
just a vast number of computations which
will slow down your computer so if you
want to calculate where
the electrons are going to be a minute
from now your computer is going to take
years perhaps the lifetime of the
universe in order to do that
however if you have a quantum computer
it can do it efficiently
so if you want to predict where the
electrons are going to be a minute from
now
perhaps it can do that calculation in a
few minutes
or in a few seconds something like that
it can do it efficiently it's not going
to take the lifetime of the universe
to do that because it can take part in
this
quantum parallelism this this different
mode of computation which
quantum computers allow for now extend
that argument
to any physical system not just an atom
not just trying to predict where the
electrons are going to be around an atom
but now extend it to ensembles okay
collections of atoms working together
lots of atoms such as would exist in a
human brain
so a a quantum computer in theory
could simulate the operation of a human
brain of course this is unfeasible right
now but in principle
in principle it's physically possible
for a quantum computer to
simulate a physical brain therefore a
human being can be simulated a person
can be simulated inside
of a quantum computer and everything
that a human mind
can do everything a human brain can do
can be simulated by a quantum computer
what are some of the more interesting
things that a human brain can do or a
human mind can do
well probably the most interesting thing
it does for our purposes and our
discussions what we're talking about
with the creation of knowledge
is comprehend things understand things
create explanations so this
particularly unique interesting capacity
of the human mind
namely the capacity to understand things
in particular the capacity to understand
the laws of physics that's just one
thing that the
human mind can do can be simulated by
a quantum computer because a quantum
computer can simulate any physical
system
including the human brain including the
human mind
comprehension understanding is a kind of
computation
it's a thing that the human brain does
now the laws of physics mandate
everything that can be done
right everything that can be done
physically
in the universe is something that has
been mandated to be done
by the laws of physics the laws of
physics have mandated
have said that orbits are approximately
circular around the sun that's one thing
the laws of physics are such that if i
drop an object here
it will go towards the ground rather
than rise up towards the sky
that's mandated by the laws of physics
the laws of physics mandate that
electrons
will repel each other they mandate that
electrons will be attracted towards
protons
positive attracts negative okay there's
all these things anything that happens
is mandated by the laws of physics
mandated or
another way of saying that is determined
determined to happen
everything that happens is determined to
happen now this is not a full
explanation of everything that happens
it's it's it's a very
i it it doesn't get us very far to say
that things are determined or mandated
for example
the laws of physics are such they
determine that whatever happens out
there in physical reality
was determined to have happened by those
same laws of physics in other words
the creation of the city of london was
determined by the laws of physics but if
you understand why
the city of london was created that's a
wrong level of analysis
trying to say well the laws of physics
mandated that london would be there
eventually
doesn't tell you much about the reasons
why london actually
happened it just says that london
doesn't obey supernatural laws it obeys
physical laws it was determined to be
there
if you want to really understand why
london is there then you'd have to talk
about
history and politics and wars
and cultures and etc etc in order to get
a
full understanding as full as we can of
why
london is there rather than just saying
it was determined to be there what's
that got to do with this
well we're just saying that
comprehension we can comprehend stuff
we can comprehend stuff we have
comprehended stuff
that capacity to comprehend was
determined by the laws of physics
mandated by the laws of physics the laws
of physics
have allowed for comprehension to exist
comprehension of everything that has
been comprehended
some of which is the laws of physics
we've been able to
understand the laws of physics the laws
of physics as we know them as we
understand them that's been mandated by
those laws of physics
now you might very well say well this
process can't go on forever now again
again go back to what macaulay said on
what principle is it
that with nothing but improvement behind
us we're to expect nothing but
deterioration before us
and and and the paraphrase which i i
took
from david deutsch to be honest david uh
paraphrased this to say
how is it that with nothing but
simplifications and unifications behind
us
how do we expect a wall of are we to
expect a wall of complexity and
incomprehensibility before us
in other words the laws of physics
hitherto
that we have gradually come to discover
over time
have always revealed themselves to be
comprehensible
our most complex laws of physics at the
moment
are comprehensible this has always been
the story
and we have continued to understand the
laws of physics
so to say that some law of physics in
the future
is going to be incomprehensible this is
a strong this is an argument that is
made by so many public intellectuals
is a belief in the supernatural it's a
belief that there will be
something that is mandated to be
incomprehensible
by those same laws but the best we know
right now and that's again
all we can go on is the best that we
know right now is that
the laws of physics as we know them
mandate their own comprehensibility
because comprehension is a computation
it's something that minds do the mind as
it comprehends has comprehended
quantum theory and computation and
marrying these things together all
physical processes
can be computed by this universal
quantum turing machine the universal
quantum computer
deutsches creation of the theory of
universal quantum computation
that such a quantum computer can
simulate the operation of
any other physical system in the entire
universe including a brain
which can comprehend the laws of physics
which themselves
are comprehensible by that brain and so
therefore the laws of physics
that allowed for brains to come to
comprehend things mandate their own
comprehensibility
so this is an important aspect of human
nature or the question of what a person
is
a person is an entity able to complete
computations
a person is made possible by the fact
the laws of physics are computable
but more than this fact a person is able
to create explanations of the rest of
physical reality
we have then a confluence of two of the
deepest strands in the fabric of reality
the theory of computation and the theory
of epistemology
a person is to be found at the
crossroads of these their brain is a
computer running software of a
critically creative kind
that is able to generate explanations it
is a unique
kind of computer the hardware is
universal a small ask after all
for all we needed was paper and the
ability to read some symbols and our
brain can do that and far more
but the software is universal too it can
comprehend
what is comprehensible and the laws of
physics are comprehensible
and it manages this by conjecturing
guessing what might be so
and then criticizing via a method of
comparing that guess to physical reality
it tests the guess and so over time the
mind comes to represent the rest of
physical reality
to increasing accuracy over time as it
learns more
how did the brain and mind come into
being by that other deep
thread of the fabric of reality
evolution by natural selection
now we do not know why it is that blind
evolution
seems to have tended towards increasing
complexity
it seems to have wandered seemingly
aimlessly towards complexity
after all for the overwhelming majority
of the history of life on earth
very little was done with dna for
billions of years nothing more complex
than
bacteria multiplied in the oceans and on
the land but then
an explosion of complexity did happen
and more than once
ultimately the emergent and yet
fundamental principles of evolution by
natural selection
led to genes for explanatory creativity
surviving and this then allowed for
memes to be not only encoded in the
minds of people
but allowed for a process of evolution
of those memes
a variety of memes that make a person a
person both rational
irrational and anti-rational but
importantly the rational means those
memes that allow for fast error
correction of ideas
and thus objective improvement of the
knowledge of their holders
has evolved a human person then has
evolved via a process of near darwinian
selection
and then that person has a mind which
contains memes subject to the selective
pressure of criticism
so that some memes do not survive and
new ideas can be created
we people therefore find ourselves at
the junction now of
three threads evolution by natural
selection the theory of computation and
universal computation at that
and the theory of knowledge the capacity
for universal explanation by the means
of conjecture and refutation
but people persist over time while also
in a constant state of change
as the ancient greek philosopher
heraclitus said in around
500 bce no man ever steps in the same
river twice for it is not the same river
and he is not the same man but he is is
he not
were he not no one would ever be
responsible for anything
are we constantly changing if so we are
not the same person as we were a moment
ago
but if we are responsible then something
must persist over time to say that
we are the same person who stole the
loaf of bread or told the liar yesterday
here we get into questions of continuous
change time and constants
something does indeed remain the same
about a person from moment to moment
that creative software running on the
hardware that is the brain
is a constant from moment to moment our
capacity to explain the world around us
does not change in some deep sense it is
who we are
in or out of the river this is a
constant while much else might change
the atoms in our bodies and the memories
and ideas we have
that remains the same that is the
defining characteristic of a person
and in that sense we are all of us
unchanging in a sense
and all of us the same as that program
that is our mind
searches for new explanations and
answers it does so because it
we all of us lack an infinite amount of
knowledge
as popper said there may be great
differences between us with regard to
minor details of what we may perhaps
know
yet we are all equal in our infinite
ignorance
that remains constant as well who are we
certainly we are in part our memories
the ideas we have that motivate our
behaviors
we are where we direct our attention
that innate capacity to explain
ponder consider and reflect we are
responsible for where we turn that
attention
and if we learn the lesson of the
importance of quiet reflection
then we are responsible for those
occasions when we do not
we are constant in our capacity to
explain we are constantly changing in
the ideas that we have
are we more to be identified with our
ideas at any one time
or our more fundamental nature of being
able to generate ideas in the first
place
we are unavoidably both our ideas and
the capacity to generate them
we are both the same as we step into and
out of the river
and yet different this is not a great
contradiction
for the final strand quantum theory
tells us
all physical objects in the universe
exist in a multiverse
and this means a person at this instant
is actually
uncountably infinite fungible entirely
identical
instances of oneself like an electron
an electron at any one place at any one
time
consists of infinitely many uncountably
infinitely many
fungible entirely identical instances of
itself
all identical that is except that in a
moment
some measure of those electrons will do
different things they will go left
rather than right
and so then the original infinite number
of electrons will partition or
differentiate itself into
two infinite groups both are infinite so
the total number has not changed
and nor is any group of those the
original or the two groups it splits
into
different in number they are after all
infinite in size the same is true of a
person
a person as they sit there and listen to
this is actually a multiversal object
you are not a single person in a single
universe you are
uncountably infinite many instances
all identical but for any choice or
indeed any quantum event
you will differentiate into groups each
group will still contain
uncountably infinite instances if there
are two groups
then there will be one group of infinite
fungible instances doing one thing
and another group doing something else
but you as a matter of fact
are not one single instance but many
all those fungible instances have the
same memory and are conjecturing the
same ideas
until they don't and it is then that the
conscious experience differentiates too
you are conscious only ever of one set
of infinite fungible instances
your copies doing something else they
are conscious of something else
so you are not them quantum theory tells
us something deep about the nature of
personhood
people are more than what we think or
what we can observe as a matter of
introspection
we too are multiversal and we have
evolved such that we can generate
knowledge about this multiverse
and knowledge tends to cause itself to
get replicated to remain
instantiated once it is created we are
forming about us
knowledge of how to remain in existence
in the multiverse
we our knowledge is thus connected to
the multiverse
because the measure of universes in
which knowledge is created
tends to increase knowledge causes
itself to remain instantiated in
physical reality
that is its nature and it is our nature
to create it
we are striving to remain in existence
we are
people we are gradually gaining a high
fidelity understanding
of all the rest of it and all the rest
of it has come together to bring us into
being
a person is it the nexus of all the
strands
in the fabric of reality now there is
something
lurking here in understanding
the mind as a computation of a kind
it is the case that the brain is
hardware and on this hardware
runs the software which i refer to as
the mind which many people refer to as
the mind
however we can't be identified with
the software the software after all can
be
instantiated in any number of physical
forms
so if we knew what the code was
so to speak for a human mind we could
write it down
on a piece of paper but that would not
be
a person and the reason it would not be
a person is because
it's not doing anything if we take the
disc
the the compact disc or the dvd or these
days of course it's
kept in the cloud somewhere but in the
old days you used to be able to have
a disk which contained upon it a
powerpoint for windows or keynote for
mac the piece of software
could be stored on a disk but in so far
it was
as it was the software it wasn't doing
anything
until you installed the software and ran
the software the software had to be
running before it was actually doing
anything so whatever the software is for
a person
it has to be running in some way
so the software for a mind has to be
instantiated in the brain
that's one thing but then it also has to
be running it has to actually be
operating for it to be a mind
which makes things all
quite complicated and this is where we
really come up against
the very edge of what we know
a human being is
software instantiated in neurons
but obviously we're not identical to our
neurons
we're something emergent we're running
on those neurons in some way
but we're not the state of those neurons
at any particular time
either we're more than that it has to be
the case that
that that a human being a
person is abstract in some way
we're not purely physical
we are as we say the software and the
software is not
purely physical it's over and above the
atoms the matter in which it is
instantiated
in the same way that the numeral for the
number five is not
identical to the number five it's a
representation of
that abstract object five that exists in
abstract space in some way and there are
many different instances there are many
different ways of representing
that number using different numerals
different symbols but they're all
equivalent to the thing they represent
but they are not
the thing that they represent that thing
that they represent is an abstract
object
not the physical instantiation thereof
so too with a person
a person is an abstraction that is
running
upon a brain but it can't be an
abstraction
in the same way that the number five is
an abstraction
after all the number five exists out
there in abstract space
but we don't we exist here in the
physical
real world in theory our
instantiation could be in silicon it
could be in some other kind of media
but at the moment it's in the where of
the neurons but
it can't be the case that we are to be
identified with the neurons obviously
because of that fact because we could be
instantiated in something else
but we're not equivalent to the
abstraction after all the abstraction of
the number five
is an unchanging perfect ontological
object
there is no area in it it is that thing
that's out there that we cannot
represent
except imperfectly in the physical world
but a person
doesn't exist out there in abstract
space it doesn't really make any sense
because if it did exist out there in
abstract space
then it would have to be a perfect
unchanging thing out there in abstract
space
this is what platonism is kind of about
that there are these
perfect objects in abstract space that
are unchanging
but a person is clearly changing over
time
is it the case that we are the one
exception to the rule where we're the
perfect abstraction which nonetheless is
able to change over time
i don't know if that makes sense but we
are an abstraction
but not an abstraction in the sense that
the number five is an abstraction
or any other kind of abstraction is an
abstraction because other abstractions
are
platonic ideals and those platonic
ideals are unchanging
but we change over time as well as
remain constant in certain ways
this constant idea of being able to
create explanations is the one constant
we carry through
from the moment of us becoming people
through our death we are generating
explanations over time we're conscious
of the physical reality in which we
exist
but we also by virtue of the fact we are
generating these explanations changing
our minds
creating new ideas in our minds those
ideas themselves are also abstractions
abstractions that are being instantiated
in our minds in various ways
so a person is this very unusual
blend between perhaps different from
physical things and abstract things
perhaps
a third kind of thing this weird
interplay between
the physical and the abstract because
as we are running as we are this mind on
this brain that's running the software
that's running on the hardware
we are not to be identified with the
particular physical instantiation we
have at the moment namely our neurons
or the particular state we have at any
one moment in time
after all we were the same person
yesterday and there will be the same
person tomorrow
modulo minor changes but the person
itself remains the same in some ways
despite the fact they're changing as
well
we're abstract but we're not abstract in
the same way
that platonic ideals are abstract so
this is where we are really reaching the
limits
of what we understand a person to be and
this is a very interesting area
for people to research
i must credit david deutsch with some
brief but private conversations i had
with him and precisely this topic and he
inspired me to
think along these lines and to continue
to think
along these lines about what the nature
of a person really is or when i say
really is
what a better understanding a better
explanation of what a person
is we don't have much of one yet but we
know it
comes in the nexus of these things that
i've talked about and importantly it
comes to bear
on how it is that us as people
existing as minds running on brains
come to be come to be these abstract
things that seem to need
a physical instantiation of a kind which
is a
thing that allows for us to both change
and remain the same
over time now there is a
another way in which physics comes to
bear on personhood
and i think it illustrates a deep way in
which we are both the same person
as we step into the river a second time
and yet also different
and this is where we consider the nature
of personhood
in the context of the multiverse
understanding
of quantum theory and in particular
david deutscher's
invocation of the term fungibility
right now as each of us occupy a place
at a particular time
according to the classical picture that
physics gives us
we are in truth uncountably many
fungible copies of ourselves david
deutscher's
chapter on the multiverse explains more
about this and my series on the
multiverse which is part of the
beginning of infinity
podcast series goes into this in some
detail
we have hitherto always understood that
to be a person
much like to be a book on a shelf is to
be a single object
occupying a single place at a single
time
in a single universe but quantum theory
the most modern variant of quantum
theory being the multiverse and the most
modern variant of that
deutsche's conception of fundamental
entities
tells us that this is not so
there is not one electron there in that
place but
infinitely many fungible instances all
in the same place
at the same time but occupying different
universes and which at some point in the
future
will partition themselves into measures
different groups
each of infinitely many fungible
instances
so too with the book on the shelf and so
too with
a person as you sit where you are
hearing these words you extend across
the multiverse
you too are a multiversal object you
have a
singular conscious experience but that
experience
is occupying many different universes
and when something different can happen
whether by your conscious choice
or the quantum action of an event where
there existed multiple possibilities
those instances differentiate you
differentiate in a sense
but you remain only ever conscious of
one measure of those instances
not all of them but those other
instances
those other copies different to you and
you
form a continuum across the multiverse
a continuously and smoothly varying
transition of instances
from you through to instances of you
that are doing something completely
different like turning off this podcast
or bumping into a stranger who will turn
out to be a lifelong friend
or being interrupted by a call that
gives you the opportunity you have been
waiting for
and there remains you still listening to
this
that is still infinitely many fungible
perfectly identical
copies the experience you are still
conscious of
constantly in a state of flux but at the
same time your conscious experience
remaining
singularly about the experience of only
one
measure of instances while the other
instances are conscious of something
else
it is they who do not step back into the
river but you do
and you are the same in that sense that
they are different
and yet you are different too because
your memory is
a constant and a change like some kind
of
linear relationship progressing through
time copies of yourself that are not you
and you are not conscious of going to do
otherwise
and you doing what you do your
consciousness being the
constant and though what it is conscious
of
all the different times and spaces will
continue to change
but you will remain in lockstep with all
those
other uncountable fungible instances of
yourself
those fungible instances that are you
as could be seen if you had some access
to a god's eye view of the multiverse
you would see you as uncountably
infinite fungible instances of yourself
in the same place
at the same time but differentiating
over time
this is a remarkable fact about what a
person is in this world view
an evolved entity of a kind which can
compute explanations
and comprehend them of the world they
find themselves in
explanations which then give them
choices so that fungible instances of
themselves
differentiate into different measures
some larger or some smaller
depending on the personality of that
person those more like you
of greater measure those unlike you of
smaller measure and so
not really you at all but so long as
they remain conscious
able to create new explanations which
give them choices about what to do next
we are the nexus of the threads
of the fabric of reality some strange
loop or not in that fabric both
unraveling
and becoming more entwined over time
something we are not
yet to fully understand but which we now
have a scientific
and philosophic glimpse into the deepest
mysteries about
[Music]
you